Let's kick off by talking about exactly what World Partition is and giving you a bit of
an overview of this.
So what is the big picture here?
So World Partition we can use to create open worlds that will require you to use a few
different tools in combination with each other.
So all of these tools are designed to be used together to help you make open worlds run
more efficiently.
And you just want to keep in mind that some of the tools can be used independently if
you know, one or a combination aren't supported.
So let's talk about World Partition in the top left here.
So World Partition is an automatic data management and distance based level streaming system
that provides a complete solution for a large world management.
So if we're making any kind of large worlds and we want to take into account level streaming,
World Partition is our go-to here.
One file per actor reduces overlap between users by saving data for instances of actors
in external files, removing the need to save main level file when making changes to its
actors.
So traditionally or historically, if you've used Unreal Engine, you may have had different
departments working on different streamed levels inside of Unreal Engine, maybe just
more for organization purposes, making sure multiple people can be working on the file.
Now you can use one file per actor, which means users can work on individual actors
and submit them to the change lists and things that you're working on rather than submitting
entire level files, which is a massive improvement to a workflow there.
We got level instancing on the top right here and level instancing is a level based workflow
that facilitates the porting of non-world partition worlds to world partition system.
We've also got data layers and data layers are systems within world partition used for
organizing your actors into separate layers.
Then we've got the HLOD.
The world partition is the hierarchical level of detail.
That's what HLOD stands for, hierarchical level of detail.
That's a system that uses custom HLOD layers to organize large amounts of static meshes
and generates a single proxy at a mesh and a material to use within that HLOD.
We got virtual textures and we need this for the MIP map to work.
So virtualizing the textures will make the MIP maps function correctly here.
We've also got virtual shadows.
The virtual texture support for our project enables us to create and use large scale textures
for lower and more consistent memory footprints at runtime.
Then using Nanite, Nanite is UE5's virtualized geometry system, which uses new internal mesh
format and rendering technology to render pixel scale and detail at high object count.
So you can have much higher poly meshes, more detail in your scene using this Nanite technology.
Other additional tools that can also help, but we won't be covering today, which is
the mass entity and smart object.
So you could do a bit of research on the documentation for mass entity and smart objects if you'd
like to go into more detail in those areas.
So let's look at world partition overview.
So when all of these tools are used together, you can make something like this.
So the top image is the city sample, aka the matrix awakens.
And then we've also got the valley of the ancients demo down in the left hand side here.